el jefe político del talibán llegó a
kabul con la misión de formar el nuevo
gobierno de afganistán el mulá abdul
ghaní baradar entró al país a principios
de esta semana después de 20 años en el
extranjero y ahora en la capital
comienzan oficialmente las negociaciones
que incluyen al ex presidente hamid
karzai y abdulá abdulá un alto
funcionario del gobierno anterior
junto a hamid karzai le dimos la
bienvenida a los miembros de la oficina
política y al equipo de negociación del
talibán intercambiamos puntos de vista
sobre los actuales desarrollos políticos
y de seguridad y un acuerdo político
inclusivo para el futuro del país
el grupo talibán prometió respetar los
derechos humanos de quienes se queden en
el país y proveerles una salida
tranquila pero miles de afganos y
extranjeros se siguen agolpando en el
aeropuerto de kabul intentando escapar
la embajada de eeuu les advirtió a sus
ciudadanos en afganistán que no vayan al
aeropuerto y es que se teme que haya una
amenaza aunque las fuerzas armadas
estadounidenses afirman que 5.800 de sus
tropas aseguran el aeropuerto
el aeropuerto permanece seguro el
personal militar de eeuu verifican las
operaciones de vuelo tanto las fuerzas
militares estadounidenses como aeronaves
contratistas y extranjeras están
operando en el aeropuerto de kabul o
update with en kabul
eeuu ha evacuado a más de 17.000
personas desde el 15 de agosto
2500 son estadounidenses por su parte
las naciones de la unión europea
aseguraron este sábado que respaldarán a
los afganos que huyan del país y desde
la base militar de torrejón de ardoz en
españa donde los están acogiendo úrsula
von der leyen advirtió que aunque tienen
contacto con el talibán no hay ningún
canal político con el grupo